hello and welcome to this blitz game
yeah backward thumb of those blitz games
yeah I've got prints panic here Vili
Hendrix had done something else is
playing this Italian game against her
yeah I mean this is very solid of course
it's usually not that exciting though
most of the time I've played with Bishop
e7 against him i believe well that's
early ok I mean I have not castle so
there is g5 h5 isn't it ok I'm going for
this I think the sir should be kind of
okay here right each 595 h4 this is
sister serve funny stuff I usually black
has fantastic compensation they have I
remember this correctly ok what else is
there h5 what can he do hey ok licking
your wage for but I have Bishop g4 I
believe age takes g5 night h7 bit weird
ok it's interesting
interesting stuff yeah of course but
we'll see i think this is kind of
interesting sometimes you can even
sacrifice the queen but i don't think
this is one of those positions because i
like 94 here but this should be possible
him I've got some very dangerous
attacking ideas 924 queen age seven
things like that okay I think magic for
is the most obvious way of doing it I
can also just play Queen age seven try
to keep it a little bit simpler Queen
age seven he might have yeah we have
three Martin but ok it's just a check
it's not now okay it's got Queen f7 so
some interesting options I mean usually
you should calculate all this before you
sacrifice the stuff but okay it's blitz
Bishop g4 is also coming into
consideration kind of a very simple way
of doing it and then just castling long
I don't know come on I have to play move
him it's taking too long already getting
canceled long it's not a bad
accomplishment note that my development
is much better very much better and the
age file is open I don't really I don't
think I need to kind of yep prove some
kind of immediate VIN here because I
should have compensation anyway okay I'm
attacking the knight now let's see if he
just tries to get it out come into h 6
carats oh that's interesting we'll
probably a good move covering it
hmm it's not easy to get this piece okay
what else do I have I'm not sure if he
is threatening much i can go bishop you
tool for example this is not a bad idea
right luckily one Bishop f2 ok took me a
while to see this move it seems good I
think you were probably no place tonight
hmm ok cooing hangs with check let's go
here it's kind of dangerous for this
Bishop is six stuff
but Kane ig4 maybe hmm cannot Google f8
unfortunately
94
all right going 26 spoons bit of
annoying but annoying they have 97 well
maybe it's not so bad I'm just taking
far too long him clearly being rusty
from not playing any chairs for two
weeks and not our blitz like it's like
one month I had the live session
yesterday okay I've got to go 97 m
why it's not so bad it's really not so
bad what i have here but down to one
minute still threatening this stuff time
morning I've no time here I mean I will
ever regain material yeah anyway maybe I
should have taken d3 here yep maybe i
don't know i would need more time to
figure this out i had some three points
down now and it's not a clear
compensation probably no compensation a
mischance silver that's it's very very
clear but i don't really know at which
point to get out of the same
yep 30 seconds and the position is not
good
yeah yeah what did I miss them okay i
don't i don't think that this was bad
for black the sacrifice that's
unfortunately very easy for right now
stuff like rupee five will win but this
probably also will win check check new
orc in black resign gym so what did i
miss there i think this is a pretty
dangerous sacrifice for for whites in
play yeah maybe queen of sevens on the
computer wants to play Queen f7 and says
I'm much better yeah it should be much
better because this Bishop g5 is just
the wrong idea so Queen age 7 which I
can give this chick but I'm regaining
one piece here yeah maybe this is better
just playing simple with Queen f7
Chapman this is this is probably pretty
okay for me and I've got two minor
pieces against rook but I have easy game
king king his seven drew comes stock
wish things black is quite quite a lot
bad am okay and this is maybe tweenage
six was a very strong move this is
something that I didn't appreciate it
all I was thinking that he would need to
move the night somehow let's say he goes
96 and this is dangerous clearly
something like this I'm just attacking
here like look here night age five I
mean all those pieces are very dangerous
and sometimes have rope takes each form
this is very dangerous stop first a
sequel but this is much easier for black
to play but just as this is just a
strong move yeah I have this but this is
just good for white yeah oops sorry
about that 97 yeah it just doesn't work
what can you do and he played all the
best movie according to the comp and he
had three points down Queenie h6 was
very strong I just I didn't see that
idea at all I was thinking okay I castle
he moves the night but Queen age 6 is
strong it's very irritating this move so
this means that Bishop g4 was wrong
between age 7 is a lot stronger I was
also thinking about this move but
there's Queen f3 which is very
problematic yeah this is just good this
is just good I also had a big hand loose
ination I was thinking this one but this
just loses straight away I was just
thinking okay this is not good which is
true it is not good but yeah so this is
pretty pretty shiny good for black check
this is the relatively best at what can
do it is under some substantial pressure
ok and Bishop g5 is usually not a great
idea once black has not cancelled I mean
yeah that's pretty the only thing that
white can do a is aged for this is farm
one this is just a better move 95 leads
to a black advantage SVS we have seen
and here I was thinking Bishop g4 or
night h7 like thinking about this which
is complicated okay an interesting game
though thanks for watching